Johnny how i jolly celebrant being
acting returning officer at the election
of a member of parliament for the
newcastle-under-lyme constituency held
on the 7th of may 2015 do hereby give
notice that the number of votes recorded
for each candidates at the election is
as follows tony cox a Conservative Party
candidate fifteen thousand eight hundred
and seventeen horeb thoroughly Labour
Party sixteen thousand five hundred and
twenty Sam Gibbons Green Party 1246
David Ernest Nixon independent 283 in
wilkes Liberal Democrat 1826 filled
would UK Independence Party you kept
7250 to and I do hereby declare that the
said Paul thoroughly is duly elected as
Member of Parliament for the
newcastle-under-lyme Institute
it's you know a long night there will be
a an even longer morning so I will keep
my remarks and very brief can I thank
all accounting staff for this marathon
efforts and security and the police
during the election I'm somewhat to
commiserate with all the other
candidates because this has been the
longest election on records and everyone
was put in a tremendous effort along
with all their helpers I want to thank
my wife Victoria my son Joe was sleeping
in the corner until a few moments ago
and the rest of my family for putting up
with with me with endless elections and
and with this relentless but very
rewarding job as the Member of
Parliament for newcastle on the line
well this is not here to see this I'm
afraid is my mother who died before
before before Christmas I still have
their immediate after this lecture some
sailing out to do I want to thank all
the Labour Party members and supporters
who helped during this campaign many of
them were here you know who you are some
summon offer be here tomorrow today I
want to thank Barry Schofield and in
particular who's been at my side since
2007 and my agent David Lee chewer dates
back to 2001 my agent when i was first
elected and also have to like to have a
special thank you to a new volunteer our
team the amazing and priceless Charlie
McGee who has mobilized so many people
to talk to so many voters that made the
difference in Newcastle this time most
of all I'd like to thank the people of
newcastle on the line it's been a
privilege to serve as the MP for my
hometown and it been a privilege to
serve for the next moment game thank you
alone
you